welcome and thank you for taking the
time to watch the following presentation
on reverse transcription quantitative
PCR my name is Gillian Brian and I'm a
global market development scientist for
our gene editing and novel modalities
team supporting our gene editing tools
and the workflows in which these tools
are used including molecular biology
during this presentation I will briefly
introduce quantitative PCR technology
and sets you can take to improve your
qpc or based experiment I will then give
a brief overview of the fundamentals of
reverse transcription qpc or some common
issues that can occur while performing
or TQ PCR and highlight how reagents
like thermistor 40 can help enhance your
or tepees your results please feel free
to submit questions during the
presentation and we will follow up with
you by email afterwards there's kick
things off here let's start with a brief
review of some of the basics so
real-time PCR also known as real-time
quantitative or qPCR determines the
actual amount of PC or product present
at a given cycle this process allows you
to measure DNA generation in the queue
PCR assay and the intensity of the
fluorescence indicates the quantity of
PCR product present researchers perform
qpc or to accurately quantify expression
of genes or DNA sequences in a
particular sample gene expression is a
common application for qpcr and is
measured by the number of copies of an
RNA transcript amplification through or
TQ PCR is necessary to detect and
quantify gene expression from small
amounts of RNA
real-time qpcr or quantitative qpcr
falls under two categories cyber green
or probe based detection cyber green
based detection uses cyber green one day
which finds two double-stranded DNA to
detect PCR product this method will
detect all amplified double-stranded DNA
including nonspecific reaction products
probe based detection uses a flora tonic
probe to enable the detection of a
specific PCR product and detect specific
amplification products only researchers
can choose to use cyber green over a
probe based detection because it is more
affordable and enabled for monitoring of
amplification of any double stranded DNA
sequence in addition multiple guys can
bind to a single amplified molecule
which increases sensitivity for
detecting amplification products the
disadvantage to cyber green detection is
that the dye itself can be an inhibitor
it can also bind to nonspecific DNA
sequences and sometimes lead to false
positives probe based qPCR may be the
method of choice for a researcher when
specificity is the most important thing
the hybridization between the probe when
the target is required to generate
fluorescence which can significantly
reduce background noise and false
positives it is possible to label these
probes with different distinguishable
reporter dyes which allows researchers
to amplify two distinct sequences in a
single reaction tube the major
disadvantage to probe base detection
includes the cost and the fact that each
target sequence requires a different
probe in terms of how the expression of
genes is analyzed this graph shows a
typical PPC or curve or output from the
cue PCR machine as you can see the
fluorescence is graphed against the
number of cycles the CT value or cycle
threshold value is shown with a green
line highlighting the point with a curve
clearly Rises off the base line to a
statistically significant degree higher
sensitivity of reagents can lead to
lower CT values which can be valuable
for researchers particularly when a
saying genes or targets that are
expressed very low levels
one thing that's often asked is do you
have any tips for successful qPCR so
described here are some tips and tricks
that you might find useful you should
always test your primers using a
standard curve this test is important
for two main reasons firstly it ensures
that the primers detect efficiently and
precisely their target which is critical
for a good qpcr experiment secondly it
can tell you the detection limit which
can help determine the appropriate
amount of DNA to use in the following
experiments for example why would you
use 10 milligrams per reaction when you
can use only one nanogram and save your
precious sample for future work
additionally to help with precision you
should do sequential solutions and
pipette the same volume of DNA in each
reaction another tip is to use water
only as one of the negative controls
which can help detect contaminants in
the reaction as well as discriminate
your test sample from background levels
of amplification and finally making sure
your DNA is high quality ie having
intact DNA at an appropriate
concentration with a good to 60 to 80
ratio will be helpful
you
when thinking about the best way to
approach to PCR experiment another
resource you might want to consider are
the Mikey guidelines these guidelines
are published by an international
research team in 2009 to address the
challenges of performing dependable qpcr
Mikey guidelines
ask for the minimum information
necessary to allow the reproduction and
quality assessments of a given Q PCR
based experiment the information
requested can be divided into
experimental design sample properties
nucleic acid extraction and quality
assessment reverse transcription target
information primer and probe details
qPCR protocol optimization and
validation details as well as data
analysis with moving forward Knight take
a closer look at or TPC or or reverse
transcription PCR this is another PC or
technique that amplifies RNA because DNA
polymerase cannot amplify
single-stranded DNA reverse
transcription is necessary to create
cDNA from an RNA template then that cDNA
is amplified using standard PC or or
possibly qpcr protocols as described in
previous slides thinking about reverse
transcription there are a number of
different orti enzymes that can be
utilized and I'd like to describe some
of those here MML V is a preferred
enzyme for longer transcripts and
reduces or NH activity AMD is a common
enzyme that has higher thermal stability
and is ideal for transcripts with
difficult secondary structures enhanced
AMD is engineered for higher
temperatures difficult secondary
structures as well as low abundant
templates
there are two different types of rt-pcr
either the one step or two set methods
one step or T PCR is a great option for
researchers who want easy and fast or
TPC or this method involves easy
handling and minimizes the risk of
contamination
since both reverse transcription and PC
or are performed in the same tube on the
other hand two step is preferred by
researchers who require a more sensitive
and potentially efficient options
buffers can be optimized for independent
reverse transcription and PC or steps
and conveniently this method also allows
researchers to store cDNA for extended
periods of time however this process
requires more preparing steps and can be
more time-consuming even when you plan
your experiments well and set everything
up carefully there can still be some
issues that you don't anticipate on
solutions to some of the most common
concerns are described here poor or no
signal may occur when there is an
inhibitor present to combat this perform
a dilution series of the PCR template
this will help determine if you can
reduce the effect of the inhibitor in
addition you can use at least three
milli moles of magnesium chloride or a
real-time PC or master mix to avoid per
signal also adjusting the minimum
extension time to 30 seconds for genomic
DNA and 15 seconds for cDNA can assist
in avoiding per signal another concern
can be seeing a signal in a negative
control in this scenario contamination
is often the culprit to avoid this use a
solution of ten percent bleach instead
of ethanol to prepare your workstation
use PCR grade water and only use it for
PC or and use a no template control to
verify the absence of contaminant
another tip is to treat samples with
purified orang aids-free DNA's before
the reverse transcription steps
lastly poor reproducibility is another
common issue for or t.q PCR primer
dimers can be avoided by reducing primer
concentration by evaluating primer
sequences for complementarity and
secondary structure and redesigning the
primers if necessary
finally a Melker of analysis can help to
determine if primer dimers are present
the majority of standard PCR is now done
using a hot start method to keep tack
inactive until it reaches reaction
temperatures in contrast the vast
majority of reverse transcription to
date has been done without hot start
even though reverse transcriptase is
have significant activity at room
temperature and even below due to this
activity at low temperature and the
highest ability of dna-rna hybrid
primers intended to be gene specific may
hybridize with undesired targets that
are partially complementary leading to
nonspecific amplification this problem
is increased substantially when multiple
primers are included for multiplex or
TPT or to address common problems with
or tpc or here is a recommended PC or
additive to increase specificity and
minimize nonspecific amplification
thermos stock or tea a PCR additive made
by thermogenic sync and distributed by
Miller for Sigma is a simple to use
reagent for one step or two step or TTC
or initiated with gene specific primers
thermos stop or tea interacts with
reverse transcriptase at low
temperatures to inhibit enzyme activity
that can lead to nonspecific products by
eliminating these errors thermistor tea
significantly increases the yield of
desired specific products and increases
assay sensitivity reverse transcriptase
activity increases at temperatures above
45 degrees Celsius enabling
transcription of the desired or na
sequence
to show the impact of thermos top or tea
both one set and two sec or TPC approach
calls for mana Plex or TPC or were
tested figure 1 shows the endpoint
fluorescent signals from hybridization
probe the results indicate that for
either one step or two set PCR over
three times as much of the HCV
amplification product was generated in
samples containing thermos top or tea a
large decrease in the amount of
nonspecific PCR product is also observed
in containing thermistor 40 figure 2
shows the cyber green fluorescent
derivatives from the post PC or melt of
the two-step or TPC or experiment above
samples containing thermos top or tea in
shown in purple lines have a single melt
peak at 85 degrees Celsius detecting the
melting of the HCV specific
amplification product in contrast
samples without thermistor 40 shown by
blue lines have a much smaller melting
peak at 85 degrees Celsius consistent
with reduced specific amplification and
have additional non specific product
Peaks
a pestle
up to the detection of a viroid that
infect palm trees the viroid is an
infectious circular or na that has
extremely high secondary structure
posing a challenge for or tpc or a
synthetic RNA with the viroid sequence
was generated using in vitro translation
the mitochondrial na d5 transcript which
is termed sliced from different regions
of the mitochondrial DNA was used as a
control for successful or tpc or in the
assay the viroid RNA was serially
diluted and mixed with a constant
concentration of prime leaf RNA one step
or TPT or in the presence or absence of
thermistor for tea was done using
non-symmetric gene specific primers
transcript reverse transcriptase from
takara and platinum tagged polymerase
ruby trojan figure 1 shows the relative
fluorescence signals from the thyroid
probe following or PPC or the signals
which reflect the quantity of
amplification product of the reaction
are significantly higher in samples with
thermistor 40 that difference is highest
in samples with low RNA concentrations
gel electrophoresis of the or TP
co-products of samples with only
palm-leaf RNA only viral RNA or both is
shown in Figure 2 samples without
thermostat 40 shall faint viroid product
bonds and high levels with nonspecific
products while only the strongly stand
specific product bans are detected in
samples with thermistor 40 for more
information on Service Authority and
other PCR additives from thermogenics
used to minimize nonspecific DNA
amplification please visit sigma comm
forward slash thermogenics
and with that I would like to thank you
for taking your time to listen to this
webinar I hope that you have a greater
understanding of the principles of
reverse transcription quantitative PCR
and how you can incorporate this
technology into your workflow if you
have any questions please feel free to
either contact us via the information
provided on the slide or visit our
websites of Sigma comm forward slash PC
or thank you and have a great day